[Applauso]
qualsiasi azione genera un impatto sulla
realtà
anche la più piccola
che cosa indossate in questo momento
sapete chi ha cucito Quei vestiti
oppure il caffè che avete bevuto questa
mattina
da dove proveniva
e ancora che cosa mangerete questa sera
a cena
ogni singola azione
ha un impatto sulla realtà in maniera
diretta oppure in maniera diretta in
quanto racchiude tutta una serie di
consensi impliciti che noi in maniera
più o meno consapevole prestiamo
La buona notizia è che una volta
compreso questo aspetto possiamo
scegliere Che tipo di impatto avere e
possiamo decidere di avere un impatto
positivo
ma facciamo un piccolo passo indietro
Che cosa significa generare un impatto
generare un impatto significa dare
origine a un cambiamento nello stato
delle cose
significa influire attivamente sulla
realtà
e significa anche sollevare
consapevolezza nelle persone per
ispirarle a percepire la realtà da nuove
prospettive affinché questo le sproni ad
agire
tutto è connesso e interdipendente
l'ambiente in cui viviamo ci influenza
in maniera diretta esattamente come noi
influenziamo l'ambiente all'interno del
quale viviamo
e chiunque noi siamo di qualunque genere
provenienza condizione fisica e
estrazione sociale chiunque Noi siamo se
lo vogliamo possiamo diventare agenti di
cambiamento
e avere un impatto positivo sulla realtà
è molto più semplice di quanto possiamo
pensare
quindi andiamo insieme alla scoperta di
quali sono gli strumenti a nostra
disposizione per recarci nel mondo e
cambiarlo in meglio
sono cresciuta da sola con mia mamma con
la quale avevo un legame molto profondo
che qualche anno fa è mancata per una
patologia oncologica
e questo evento molto doloroso mi ha
costretta a pormi delle domande e
indagare le risposte a queste domande
che cosa ho capito
ho compreso che è indispensabile
modificare i nostri stili di vita in
un'ottica più sostenibile sia per il
bene del pianeta che ci ospita sia per
la nostra stessa salute
E ho deciso che avrei fatto tutto ciò
che fosse stato nelle mie possibilità
per divulgare questo messaggio
proviamo a pensarci
l'aria che respiriamo ogni giorno è
satura di gas nocivi
le nostre acque sono inquinate i cibi di
cui ci nutriamo sono Iper processati e
sempre più poveri di nutrienti
e abbiamo smarrito il contatto con la
natura al punto tale per cui siamo così
travolti dalla frenesia delle nostre
vite che certi giorni arriviamo a sera
senza quasi avere più respiro vi risuona
siamo vittime di consumi compulsivi alla
costante ricerca e rincorsa di
quell'acquisto all'esito del quale
magicamente si manifesterà la felicità
senza renderci conto che in realtà
stiamo soltanto sofferendo a dei bisogni
irreali
indotti da campagne di marketing in
grado di farci percepire come
indispensabile anche la più superflua
delle merci
e così partiamo alla rincorsa del nuovo
acquisto del nuovo bene in quella che
poi si rivela essere una rincorsa senza
fine
vi Domandate mai Ma in che direzione sto
andando
ho deciso di condividere a titolo di
esempio con le persone che mi circondano
il mio stile di vita Un po' più
sostenibile affinché questo possa essere
di ispirazione al cambiamento e quando
capita che anche solo una persona mi
racconti Sai dopo quella chiacchierata
che abbiamo fatto Ho ridotto il consumo
di carne e mangia un po' più vegetale
Oppure ho abbandonato l'uso dell'auto
privata per andare al lavoro in favore
di mezzi pubblici O bicicletta o ancora
quando qualcuno mi racconta Sai mi sono
avvicinato avvicinata finalmente i
consumi di seconda mano ecco li so di
aver avuto un impatto positivo sulla
realtà
Magari solo su una due o forse tre
persone
ma quell'una due o tre persone potranno
diventare a loro volta agenti di
cambiamento e ispirare altre persone al
cambiamento le quali potranno ispirare
qualcuno a propria volta in quella che
mi Auspico possa essere un virtuoso
effetto a cascata
non è facile cambiare ma da qualche
parte bisogna partire e dunque perché
non partire da noi stessi
proviamo ad analizzare un attimo il
contesto in cui viviamo ok
l'economia lineare il nostro modello
economico va dalla produzione di un bene
attraverso il suo utilizzo per arrivare
alla produzione di un rifiuto
abbiamo prodotto così tante rifiuti che
non siamo più in grado di smaltirli in
maniera adeguata
e ce lo conferma il livello di
inquinamento delle nostre terre dei
nostri Mari dell'acqua e dell'aria
un altro esempio il modello capitalista
e il consumismo che ne deriva
abbiamo eroso le risorse della terra ha
una velocità tale per cui queste non
hanno più tempo sufficiente per
rigenerarsi
e ce lo conferma Lover Sud dei che
quella data che viene calcolata e ci
comunica Qual è quel giorno dell'anno in
cui abbiamo esaurito tutte le risorse
del pianeta che ci sarebbero dovute
bastare per 365 giorni
non so se sapete Quando è caduto l'over
su Day del 2022 di quest'anno
il 28 luglio Noi il 28 luglio di
quest'anno a livello planetario avevamo
esaurito tutte le risorse a nostra
disposizione per l'arco dell'anno e cosa
è successo niente abbiamo continuato ad
attingere alle risorse ovviamente
disponibili per il tempo successivo e
così via
questa data che si chiama oversud Day
viene calcolata anche a livello
nazionale
e per l'Italia quest'anno lo presso Day
è stato
il 13 maggio
siamo letteralmente divorando il pianeta
e abbiamo leso e stravolto i suoi
equilibri in una maniera disastrosa
e ce lo confermano i fenomeni
meteorologici estremi a cui stiamo
assistendo
perché non si chiama maltempo si chiama
crisi climatica
nel periodo che va tra gennaio 2022 e
giugno 2022 Secondo i dati
dell'osservatorio città clima di
Legambiente si sono verificati 132
eventi meteorologici estremi il numero
più alto Mai registrato negli ultimi
decenni
pensiamo alla siccità estrema a cui
abbiamo assistito quest'anno che ha
provocato ingenti danni alla produzione
agricola
al drammatico alluvione nelle Marche
cambia tutto 11 vittime
e altrettante sono state causate dal
crollo di parte del ghiacciaio della
Marmolada a cui si aggiungono gli
incendi a Pantelleria le trombe d'aria
in Liguria in Toscana senza parlare
delle catastrofe oltreoceano perché sto
menzionando questi eventi drammatici
perché voglio sottolineare quanto questa
emergenza sia attuale e quanto ci tocchi
da vicino
e altrettanto attuali Dunque devono
essere le soluzioni che noi mettiamo a
terra per arginare questa crisi
dunque
è indispensabile che provvedimenti
efficaci significativi arrivino
dall'alto da chi si trova in posizione
apicali di grandi multinazionali di chi
si trova i vertici dei governi questo è
insindacabile
Eppure l'attesa che ciò avvenga non può
e non deve
deresponsabilizzarci ciascuno di noi
dall'agire anche in prima persona
noi infatti nelle nostre mani nelle mani
di ciascuno di noi abbiamo un potere
straordinario
ed è quello legato alla nostra qualità
di consumatori
attraverso ogni nostra singola scelta di
consumo ogni singolo giorno
noi esprimiamo un voto noi dichiariamo
un consenso a determinate politiche a
determinate produzioni
faccio un esempio forse un po' banale ma
per capirci meglio se mi trovo a Milano
centro e acquisto per €3,99 una
maglietta con appunto un'etichetta media
in Bangladesh per esempio cosa sto
facendo io non sto solo acquistando
quella maglietta Io sto dichiarando
esplicitamente cara azienda che hai
prodotto questa maglietta
delocalizzando la tua produzione nel sud
est asiatico per avvalerti di sgravi
fiscali dove il costo della manodopera è
bassissimo e non esistono tutele per le
lavoratrici e lavoratori deturpando del
territorio attraverso l'estrazione di
materie prime in maniera irrispettosa
inquinando le acque
A me va bene perché io acquisto questa
maglietta io acconsento alla tua
produzione e te lo dichiaro attraverso
il mio gesto D'Acquisto
Ma se invece noi iniziamo a utilizzare
questo potere che abbiamo nelle nostre
mani al contrario dicendo No a me non va
bene questo tipo di produzione questo
applicabile a qualunque settore
aziendale naturalmente a me non va bene
questo tipo di produzione perché non è
sostenibile da un punto di vista
ambientale e sociale non è etico quindi
io non ti do azienda i miei soldi per la
tua produzione se li vuoi devi cambiare
sembra banale ma questo sta accadendo
perché tantissime grandi aziende stanno
prendendo la direzione della
sostenibilità C'è chi lo fa in maniera
genuina e chi lo fa in maniera meno
genuina Ma questo è un altro discorso Il
punto è che se le aziende lo stanno
facendo un peso le nostre scelte ce
l'hanno e noi possiamo decidere Qual è
la direzione che prende il mercato e
quindi Qual è la direzione che prende la
politica
arrivati a questo punto si aprono due
strade davanti a noi
la prima strada è quella di scegliere di
fare come abbiamo sempre fatto oppure di
disinteressarci del tutto della
questione
così facendo In entrambe le ipotesi noi
scegliamo di rimanere parte del problema
In alternativa possiamo decidere di
agire adottando stili di vita più
sostenibili e quindi diventando parte
della soluzione ma qui non c'è
neutralità
o si decide di cambiare ciascuno di noi
oppure rimaniamo parte del problema
e dunque la domanda che sorge spontanea
adesso è Ok cambiamo Ma come si fa a
cambiare Come posso modificare la mia
vita in maniera un po' più sostenibile
Beh Prima di tutto e c'è l'assunzione di
consapevolezza che cosa significa
assumere consapevolezza è legato alle
informazioni informiamoci in maniera
adeguata da fonti attendibili
Su quale lo stato in cui versa il
pianeta perché solo attraverso una
genuina assunzione di consapevolezza e
sviluppo di senso critico possiamo
mettere in atto un cambiamento che sarà
duraturo nel tempo senza consapevolezza
nessun cambiamento destinato a durare
In secondo luogo
Mettiamoci nell'ottica di un percorso
è impensabile alzarsi una mattina e dire
Va bene stravolgo la mia vita in
un'ottica un po' più sostenibile le
nostre abitudini sono profondamente
radicate in noi Sono gesti automatici e
quindi è indispensabile partire da le
cose piccole da ciò che ci risuona per
qualcuno sarà semplice usare un po' meno
l'auto privata per qualcuno sarà
semplice adottare una dieta un po' più
vegetale per qualcun altro sarà semplice
qualcos'altro ancora ognuno secondo le
proprie risorse e compatibilmente con le
proprie esigenze L'importante è
attivarsi L'importante è iniziare fare
il primo passo
in terzo luogo condividiamo i benefici
che traiamo dall'adozione di stile di
vita più sostenibili sono tantissimi
benefici In primo luogo economico in
secondo luogo soprattutto per la nostra
salute condividiamo questi benefici con
chi ci circonda inspiriamo altre persone
a prendere parte attiva al cambiamento
e infine ma non meno importante agiamo
sul territorio
cerchiamo indaghiamo sui nostri
territori di riferimento Quali sono
tutte quelle realtà che giorno dopo
giorno si adoperano per la costruzione
di un futuro più sostenibile
partecipiamo agli eventi alle iniziative
agli incontri o magari mettiamo a
disposizione le nostre competenze
professionali o anche solo il nostro
tempo a titolo volontario
ma iniziamo ad agire è indispensabile
oggi che ciascuno di noi si assume la
propria responsabilità e contribuisca
facendo la propria parte
e se è vero che un gesto piccolo una
piccola nuova abitudine in sé per sé non
cambia il mondo
e altrettanto vero che lo cambierà la
nuova cultura che creiamo attraverso
l'adozione di nuovi stili di vita
Perché è così che si attiva il
cambiamento la strada È lunga da qualche
parte bisogna iniziare E se inizia così
un giorno alla volta Un passo alla volta
e un gesto alla volta
e ogni volta che pensiamo che ogni
nostro piccolo gesto non abbia peso
proviamo a immaginarlo applicato a
milioni a migliaia a miliardi di persone
e allora iniziamo a vedere quel peso
e se è vero che ogni gesto può fare la
differenza perché la fa e Ogni azione ha
un impatto sulla realtà
La domanda è tu
Che tipo di impatto scegli di avere
Grazie
[Applauso]